All right, good morning. So today, we are
going to talk about what is both a basic device
in itself, the amplifier, and it also serves
as a real key example of both nonlinear analysis
and small signal analysis.
So, today, dependent sources and amplifiers.
So, let me first spend a few seconds just
pointing out to you some of the key points
from our previous lectures. I also want to
point out that each chapter in the course
notes has a summary at the end of it.
And if you take a quick scan of the summary
at the end of each chapter, it highlights
the major takeaway points from each chapter.
It stresses what's important, and if you have
to remember a few things, what are those things
to remember? So, to quickly review, we talked
about a few primitive elements: resistors,
voltage sources, and so on.
And by now, you should have the facility to
play around with these device elements. And
then we talked about the Node method, and
this is kind of the workhorse of 6.002. When
in doubt, use the Node method.
OK, and this will work both for linear circuits
and nonlinear circuits. OK, so if you see
a problem, or if you see a situation in real
life that requires analysis, then as a first
step, you should try to think of whether you
could apply some of the key intuitive shortcut
methods, superposition.
One of my favorites, the Thevenin method,
the Norton method, or the method that involves
composition, that is very quickly analyzing
circuits that have resistors in series and
parallel. OK, so if you can apply one of these
quick, intuitive, shortcut methods, go do
so.
If you can't, then usually you can resort
to the Node method irrespective of whether
the circuit is linear or nonlinear. So the
last week was focused on the nonlinear method
or nonlinear circuits, and we spent the first
lecture talking about a straightforward application
of the Node method, which gave us a bunch
of nonlinear equations that we had to solve.
In the last lecture, we talked about the small
signal trick. What we said is if you look
at the whole space of nonlinear circuits,
then within that space, if we focus on small
variations, small perturbations about an operating
point, then even the behavior of nonlinear
circuits in that small regime would be linear.
So small signal method. And as an example,
I showed you how I could take a highly nonlinear
device like the garage door opener LED, and
using that, build a pretty nice transmitter
that would transmit music.
And as long as we kept the signal small, and
operated the device in a region where its
transfer curve was relatively smooth, and
I biased, or set the operating point appropriately,
I would get a linear, small signal response.
OK. So today, we're going to do a couple things.
We're going to look at dependent sources.
And the reading for this is section 2.6 of
your course notes. And, the dependent source
will be a new element in your tool chest.
We will also do amplifiers, and amplifiers
are in section 7.1 and section 7.2 of your
course notes. So, before I begin with dependent
sources, I'm just a huge believer in motivating
things with real world examples.
OK, so let me start by motivating: why we
need an amplifier? Why do we need to do things
like this? Or why do we even bother? And,
spend a few minutes really getting you to
appreciate that amplification is fundamental.
OK, it's as foundational to life as high fat
potato chips and stuff like that. So, let's
do some basic examples here. So first, let
me talk about, why do we need to amplify signals.
Why amplify? Why do we care about building
an amplifier? So, an amplifier, think of a
little box, and apply some sort of small input.
And I get a larger output. In this example,
this may be a voltage with a swing of 10 mV,
and in this case, the output might be another
voltage with a swing of, say, 100 mV. And
commonly, the amplifier, in addition to an
input and an output, input port and output
port, may also contain the power port, OK,
so that I can apply a power supply to the
amplifier because commonly as an amplifier
signal, I'm looking for a power gain as well,
an increase in the power provided by the output.
So, that's an abstract definition of an amplifier,
and let's take a look at an example of why
we may need this. So let's say I have a small,
useful signal, and let's say the signal has
1 mV peak to peak.
And, I'm looking to transmit the signal over
a wire to some other point. But let's say
that in this environment, I get a bunch of
noise that is in a noisy environment. And
in this environment, let's assume that some
noise may get superimposed.
And if I have a 1 mV signal, and 10 mV of
noise, then what I end up with at the output
is something that looks like this. And it's
really hard to distinguish my 1 mV signal
from that large amount of noise.
On the other hand, if I do the following,
if I took the signal and passed the signal
to an amplifier, and I amplified the signal
to be a much larger version of the same signal,
let's say in this particular situation 100
mV peak to peak signal.
OK, so I magnified the signal by a factor
of 100. OK, let's say it's a linear amplifier,
I linearly amplified signal to be 100 mV,
then in that case, if I had a noise on top
of this, it's going to be less discernible.
The signal will look like this.
OK, my 10 mV noise would add on to it. But,
this is still pretty decent. I can still recognize
the input. And so, this is one application
of amplification. If I need to send something
from point A to point B as an analog signal,
then an amplified signal is less prone to
noise attacks than a small signal.
Not surprisingly, a large number of devices
that are used in everyday life have amplifiers
built into them. So, get a little cell phone,
and virtually every single cell phone contains
an amplifier. By the way, this is an all digital
cell phone.
It's a Kyocera, I forget the number now. It's
completely digital. OK, although they say
it's completely digital, it turns out that
a significant fraction of the circuitry is
analog, in particular, so digital is sort
of a marketing term to say that there's something
special about this.
But remember, there's a bunch of analog stuff.
So, here's my little antenna from the cell
phone. OK, and typically the first thing that
happens to a signal as it comes out of the
antenna in your cell phone is, look at cell
phone circuits, or cell phone systems would
be something that looks like this, OK, this,
and may have a label LNA.
If someone were to take a guess at what LNA
might stand for? What's that? Linear amplifier.
That's pretty good. So that's LNA. Close enough.
A is correct. It's amplifier. What does L
and N stand for? Low noise.
OK, so this stands for low noise amplifier.
So, I get a really rinky dinky small signal
here, and then the low noise amplifier amplifies
a signal. And in real cell phones, and for
that matter, in your 802.11b, or 802.11a,
or 802.11g wireless cards, same thing.
Antenna, low noise amplifier, and then you
may have a bunch of processing. And commonly,
you have a bunch of analog processing. And
then, you convert the analog to a digital
signal. OK, I recall last week I asked somebody
in class here, how would we transmit the signal
from point A to point B without it being impacted
way too much by noise, and he said, oh, go
digital.
Good point. OK, so if I go digital, I can
transfer the signal without noise being a
real factor. But the analog to digital converters
need the signal strengths to be a given value
before it can chop it up into digital levels.
OK, so an amplifier is very fundamental. OK,
and so in this case, what may be a signal
of a few tens of microvolts to be amplified
to some large enough value that it can be
further processed. So, that's application
of amplification in the analog domain.
Let me talk about amplification in the digital
domain. So, that's in the analog domain. This
amplification is in the domain that I have
both analog and digital. OK, and now let me
talk about amplification in the digital domain,
OK? I'm going to argue that amplification
is absolutely foundational to the digital
domain.
OK, the digital abstraction would not occur
if I did not have basic amplification. OK,
and the next minute and 37 seconds I will
prove that to you, OK? So, let's do so. So,
let's suppose I have a very simple digital
system, and the system simply contains a pair
of inverters.
So, if I send a one here, it's a zero here
and a one here, which is a very simple, trivial,
digital system. And here's the input. Here's
the output. And we said that for digital systems
of this sort to work, they have to follow
a static discipline.
OK, our signals and our circuits must follow
a discipline for them all to work together.
And, the discipline we described comprised
of signals adhering to certain voltage thresholds
so that all the components in the system could
agree on what comprised a zero, and what comprised
a one, OK? So the way we did that was we said
that you would have a threshold called VIH,
V input high, and another threshold called
VIL, V input low.
OK, and we said that this circuit must recognize
signals that are higher than VIH, 3 V for
example as a one, and simultaneously, any
signal that has a voltage level less than
VIL, say, two volts, should be recognized
as a zero.
That was the input constraint. On the output,
it had a similar set of constraints, where
we had tougher constraints on devices, where
we said that the output had to satisfy a output
low constraint, output high constraint.
What this said is that for this circuit to
be called a good digital circuit that satisfies
the static discipline, signals that were ones
here should be recognized as such. And if
I am producing a one as an output, then the
signal level should be higher than VOH.
Similarly, if the signal's a zero, then it
should be less than VOL. So as an example,
this may be 2 V, this may be 3 V, and this
may be 4 V, and this may be 1 V. OK, so input,
I should recognize 2 V and less as a zero,
but at the output I have to produce a very,
very low value, 1 V.
So, I have some noise margin. So as an example,
say if I made a plot of the input/output,
so I get my VIL here and VIH here. This is
time. This would comprise a valid digital
signal: zero, one, zero, one, and so on.
OK, now, I had a tougher set of constraints
at the output. I would have VOL, VOH. So,
at the output, OK, I'm required to stretch
the ones and zeros to be further apart from
each other so that I get noise margin, and
the corresponding signal for our little circuit
there would look like so.
Right, if this is a valid input, then this
would be the corresponding, valid output.
OK, and need I say more? OK, you can see that,
intuitively, look, there's amplification happening
here, and the reason is that VOL is chosen
to be less than VIL, and VOH is higher than
VIH.
So therefore, the signal has to be stretched.
The signal has to be amplified. OK, and what's
the minimum amplification needed for the system
to work? The minimum amplification is if I
had a signal that looked like this.
OK, that barely skimmed the VIL, VIH level.
OK, so if signal were this high peak to peak,
VIH minus VIL, and what's the absolute minimum
signal at the output? It would look something
like this. OK, barely skimming VOL and VOH,
OK, so the corresponding output level would
be VOH minus VOL.
OK, so this is the absolute minimum amplification
that my digital circuit has to provide. OK,
and notice, VOH is larger than VIH. VOL is
smaller than VIL. Therefore, this quantity
needs to be greater than one.
OK, so I've shown you both a simple, graphical,
intuitive explanation, and this is a slightly
more formal proof that even the digital circuit
really requires to have amplification built
into it, if it is to satisfy valid static
disciplines.
Yes? Yes. The question is, is that the same
as gain? Good question. Yes, the term amplification
has many, many variants. You could say gain.
You could say amplification. You could say
increase in signal strength, and so on and
so forth.
And in fact, when talking about low noise
amplifiers, people sometimes talk about having
the low noise, high gain amplifier at the
input stage. OK, so let me pause there in
terms of motivation. So, I believe I've motivated
every which way: pure analog, analog/digital,
and digital.
OK, so I've covered every single base here.
And so, we need amplification. OK, so let's
look at how to build a fundamental, primitive
device called the amplifier. Before we do
that, however, let me take a quick detour.
It will be convenient for me, as I show you
how to build an amplifier, to introduce a
new device, a new element, called the dependent
source. OK, let me introduce a new device
for your arsenal of devices, along with resistors,
You learned about a MOSFET, a switch, voltage
source, current source, and now a dependent
source.
So, a dependent source looks like this, OK,
has an output port, and has a control port.
So, a dependent source in its simplest form
has two ports: an input port and an output
port. Remember, a port is a convenient pairing
of terminals, and I apply signals to such
terminal pairs.
But this is a abstract diagram for a dependent
source, and to get a little bit more specific,
let me show you an example of a dependent
source. So, let's say, here's my input, and
I label the terminal variables for the input.
VC is the voltage applied to the input, and
IC is the current into this terminal here.
And, here is the symbol for the dependent
source. Much like a current source or a voltage
source has a circle around it, the corresponding
symbol for a dependent source is like so.
So this example, for instance, is a dependent,
current source. I can apply the corresponding
output variables, I0, OK, and I can say that
the current, I, is some function. In this
example, I've designed the example that the
current through the current source, I, is
some function of the input voltage or the
control voltage, VC.
OK, so notice that the current through a current
source, the current through this current source,
I, is some function of another variable. OK,
in this example, it's the voltage across its
control port.
Not surprisingly, this device is called a
voltage controlled current source -- -- or
a VCCS. So, in like manner I can also devise
other forms of sources. You can think of this
is a device where a voltage controls an output
current.
You can think of all other combinations, current
controlling current, voltage controlling voltage,
current controlling voltage, and so on. So,
another example, I give you another dependent
source, and in this situation, my output current
is controlled by an input current, VC.
IC rather. And I claim that I for this one
is some function of a current, IC. OK, it's
another dependent source where the output
current for its output port is related to
the current, IC. And, this is a current controlled
current source.
OK, it's a current controlled current source.
And, if I had lots of time on my hands, and
I was wanting to kill time, I'd sit around
drawing for you, other types of dependent
sources. I would draw for you a current controlled
voltage sourced, and I could also draw for
you a voltage controlled voltage source.
OK, so that's an abstract diagram for such
a source. And so, let's do a few examples
involving elements like this. To begin, just
so you can build up your intuition, let me
start by doing a very simple circuit, involving
an independent current source,
OK, just so we can relate back to what we've
been doing so far.
So, let's say I have some resistor, and I
have a standard current source with current
I nought. This is an independent current source.
Remember the circle? And, some resistor, R,
and let's say I care about the voltage across
the resistor.
OK, so I have a current I nought flowing through
it. So, I can very quickly write down VR as,
simply, I0 R. OK, it's the drop across the
resistor when a current I nought flows through
it. OK, so this is what you've been used to
doing.
Correspondingly, I can do an example with
a dependent current source. And, as an example,
I'll use a voltage controlled current source.
OK, a voltage controlled current source is
a dependent current source whose output current
depends on the voltage applied at the control
port of the current source.
So let me build a little circuit. OK, so here's
my current. And let's say it's VC IC for the
control port, and similarly, let's say my
current I here is some function of the control
port voltage. And let's say, to be specific,
there is some K over VC, some function.
OK, there are a variety of dependent sources
that can be built, and here's a hypothetical
device where the output current is mathematically
related to the input in the following manner.
So, let me build a circuit of the following
form.
So, let's add the resistor, R, and here's
my circuit, OK? And, as before, let me look
to figuring out what VR is. So, notice that
I have to supply some voltage at the input
so that the output can depend on the input
because right now I don't know what the input
here.
So what I'll do is let me apply VR over here.
OK, so let me make this connection. OK, let
me make the connection from here to here.
What I've done is I've applied VR at the control
port of the dependent current source.
OK, and I often draw a circuit like this.
This looks pretty messy. I will often draw
the circuit like so: R, VR. OK, short form
circuit drawing would look like this. This
is a complete drawing that I show you the
explicit connections of the control port,
but oftentimes, when the control port does
not have any other impact in the circuit,
you can eliminate, don't explicitly show the
control port.
Rather, you can simply show the dependence
of the output current on whatever circuit
variable you have in mind. So, you can draw
the diamond like this, and see its current
is some function of VR. VR in this is case
is K divided by VR, OK?
OK, so let's go ahead and analyze this little
circuit here, and look at what this might
give us.
Our goal, as before, is to find out the value,
VR. So, in this case, let's apply the Node
method to this node, and sum the currents
into that node to be zero. OK, so sum the
currents going into that node to be zero.
The current going down is simply VR divided
by R. OK, and that is equal to the current
that is going out of the node. And so that
is equal to F of VR. And I know that F of
VR is given by K divided by VR.
OK, a simple application of the Node method.
So then, I collect VR's on the left hand side,
and I get VR squared is K times R, OK, and
VR is simply the square root of KR. There
you go: I'm done. OK, I've gone ahead an applied
the Node method to this, and when have to
figure out the current here, I simply reflect
the fact that it depends on VR like so, and
I just go ahead and solve the circuit.
Remember, the workhorse of the circuit industry,
the Node method, when in doubt, apply it.
It simply works. And notice, this is a nonlinear
circuit. OK, the dependence is nonlinear,
and I get the response like so.
So, to plug in some numbers, supposing K was
10 to the minus 3 amperes per volt, and R
was one kilo ohm, then I can plug the numbers
in and the kilo here cancels with the 10 to
the minus 3, and I get VR equals 1 V.
OK, this simply says, if I build a circuit
like this, then this voltage here will be
1 V. So, again, as long as you remember that
the dependent source is simply another little
circuit element, OK, and you usually draw
just the output port for dependent sources,
and reflect the way that the control affects
the current, that'll suffice, and you get,
through the application of the Node method,
the variable you're interested in.
Let's do another example,
OK, of another fun current source, a voltage
controlled current source, and look at it
this way. So, let's say I have a resistor,
and I have a current source, a resistor, RL,
and this goes to some, I apply a VS here.
Remember this short form notation; that's
simply applying a supply VS between that node
and the ground. OK, and let us say the current
IV through the device is some function of
the current at its control port.
OK, so I'm not going to show you that. But
remember that the device already looks like
this, that there is a control port here. I'm
not showing that to you. And let us say that
I apply some voltage, VI, to the input port.
The reason we often don't show the input port
is for many practical dependent sources, the
input has no other effect on the circuit.
So, for example, in this case, the input has
infinite resistance looking in.
So therefore, if I apply a VI here, it doesn't
draw any current from VI. I simply apply the
voltage, VI. It doesn't affect the circuit
in any other way except in terms of how it
controls the current ID.
So let's say the current ID is some function
of VI because VI is applied at the control
port. OK, and as I pointed out before, I oftentimes,
just for clarity, just to show this dependent
source explicitly.
OK, so let's work the example. So as I said,
I'm going to choose ID to be F of VI, and
let's pick some specific parameters here.
Let's say it's K by two VI minus one, both
squared. OK, and let's say this is true for
VI less than equal to one volt.
And let us also say that ID equals zero for
VI less than one volt. OK, it's a dependent
source, and it can have various forms of dependences
on the input. And, I just picked an example
of some hypothetical, or as yet, hypothetical
dependent source, the current through which
is related to the input using a square law
relation, VI minus one all squared as long
as VI is greater than one.
And if VI is less than one, then the current
is simply zero, it shuts off. So, I can go
ahead and apply. So, let's say I want to find
out V0 versus VI. So, I care about finding
out V0. V0 is the voltage of this node with
respect to ground.
OK, so it's a slightly more complicated circuit
than you saw up here, than you saw up there.
So, let's go ahead and do this example. Start
by applying the workhorse of the circuits
business, the Node method, and let's start
with doing this for VI.
Let's first do it for VI greater than one,
notice the behavior of this is different for
different ranges of VI. So let's first do
it for VI greater than or equal to one and
apply the Node method. Node method says sum
the currents going into this node; we know
the voltage at this node.
It's VI. We know the voltage at this node.
It's VS. OK, the only unknown is V nought.
And so, let's go ahead and write the node
equations for that node. So, the current going
up, let me simply equate the current going
up to the current that has been supplied by
this particular node here.
And, that should equate that the two of them
should sum to zero, the current going up plus
the current going down should sum to zero.
So, I get V0 minus VS divided by R. That's
the current going up.
Plus, the current going down must sum to zero,
plus ID must sum to zero. And ID is going
to be K divided by two VI minus one all squared.
That must equal zero. Straightforward application
of Node method, current going up plus the
current going down at this node should equal
zero because the total current leaving the
node must be zero, OK? So I can go ahead and
simplify this, multiply it throughout by,
I call this RL here.
So, multiply it throughout by RL, and move
all of this to the other side, so I get VS
divided by RL, multiply it throughout by RL.
I get VS at this side. I take this term to
the other side. This becomes a minus.
RL multiplies here, so I get KRL. That's the
expression I get. V nought is VS minus KRL
divided by two times VI minus one all squared.
Let me put a box around this because I will
be referring to this more times in 6.002 for
a variety of reasons than probably any other
equation on Earth.
OK, this is the first time you saw it. You
saw it here. OK, mark it down. You'll smile
every other time you look at it in quizzes,
and you will find out why this comes up very
often in 6.002. So, I'll just give you a few
seconds to savor this big moment in your 6.002
life.
All right, OK, so it's pretty simple actually.
I mean, there's really not much. A lot of
this stuff is just a plain old, simple application
of the Node method, and things just fall out.
It's just so simple.
So, the V nought, I apply the Node method,
I get V nought for this nonlinear circuit.
I can also it for VI less than one. For VI
less than one, when VI is less than one, what
happens? ID is zero. OK, since ID is zero,
think of this as an open circuit.
OK, so there's no voltage drop across RL.
And, this voltage V nought is equal to VS.
So, I like to see things in pictures. I'm
not an equations kind of person. I'm much
more of a graphical person.
So, let me draw a little graph to show how
V nought, to see the form of V nought, and
then let's study that little system a little
bit more carefully. So, this is page seven,
and we plot V nought versus VI for you.
And let's take a look at how this really simple
circuit looks. This has got nothing. It's
got an RL resistor connected to a supply,
and a dependent current source, and I apply
some voltage VI at the input.
It's a very, very simple circuit. So, let's
see. So as long as VI is less than one,
the output stays at VS. OK, that makes intuitive
sense, right? As long as the current here
is zero, this is like an open circuit here.
If this is an open circuit, then effectively,
V nought is simply the voltage VS. V nought
simply appears here. If you want to grunge
through KVL and KCL, go ahead. VS minus RL
times the current is V nought, and the current
is zero so it's, yes.
So, this is simply VS. When VI goes above
one volt, fun stuff begins to happen. OK,
when V nought goes above one volt, then this
equation applies because VI is greater than
one. This equation applies.
And, when VI is a one, one minus one is zero.
This term cancels out, so this is VS. OK,
phew! So, I start off here. As VI increases,
what happens now? As VI increases, this term
here becomes increasingly negative, OK, subtracting
from VS.
OK, so I get some behavior like this. V nought
begins to drop. And it makes intuitive sense,
right? As ID begins to increase, the voltage
here will begin to drop because I'm drawing
more and more current through RL.
I'm dropping more and more across RL. So more
and more drops across RL, so V nought begins
to drop too. So, it looks something like this.
I'll show you a little demo, but my claim
is that you have just seen an amplifier.
Whoa. You just saw an amplifier. So, I snuck
an amplifier by you, OK? So, I
just snuck an amplifier past you. I'll show
you why in a second. So, let's take a look
at this waveform here. Let's not worry about
what happens way down here.
We'll talk about that a little later. But,
look at this curve here. I claim there is
amplification in the following sense. Focus
on some change in the input voltage, delta
VI, OK, and for that change in input voltage,
I get some change in the output voltage.
OK, for some change in the input voltage,
delta VI, I get some change in the output
voltage. And guess what? In this, at least
the way I have drawn it, delta V nought divided
by delta VI, if I can find regions of the
curve where this is greater than one, then
I have amplification.
OK, so what's that saying? What that's saying
is that if I apply some voltage here, OK,
and I change that voltage by a small amount
from, let's say, 2 V to 2.1. OK, I am going
to find the output voltage.
Let's say I go from 2 V to 2.1 here. OK, abstractly
out there, I might have an output that goes
from three to, let's say, two V perhaps. OK,
so for a 0.1 change here, I'm going to get
a bigger drop here, so from 3 V to 2 V, giving
me an amplification in this little circuit.
OK, so we'll see this again and again, and
you'll really understand it. So, I have a
small change in the input, and I have a corresponding
larger change in the output. So, I've shown
you an amplifier.
I haven't shown you a linear amplifier. There's
an extra charge for that. OK, that'll happen
later. OK, all I've shown you so far is an
amplifier, and this happens to be a crummy
amplifier. It's a nonlinear amplifier because,
notice, this is not linear.
It's a nice little curve, and so it's not
linear. But, I promised you an amplifier,
and I'm cheap, and that's all you get for
now. OK, we'll see linear stuff later, but
for now, I have a little amplifier.
So, let's do some real numbers, and plot some
numbers down, and also look at a demo. So,
let's do an example. Let's say VS is 10 V,
that the K is two milliamps per V squared,
and let's say RL is five kilo-ohms, OK? So,
let me substitute these values into that equation,
and I get V nought is, VS is ten.
So, it's ten minus, KRL divided by two. So,
K is two milliamps. Two milliamps times five
kilo-ohms is ten divided by two gives me five,
and VI minus one squared. That's what I have.
I just plug in a bunch of numbers, and that's
what I get.
So, what I'll do is let me just do a little
table for you, and plot using real numbers,
simply plot those values for you.
So when VI is zero, my current is zero, and
I get - oh, that equation doesn't apply, by
the way; that applies when VI is greater than
one. Ok. So as long as VI is less than one,
my output is simply VS, the output is simply
ten volts.
Ok, so all the way up to one, my output V
is - all the units are all volts - that's
what I get.
I come down to 2, I plug in two for VI, 2
minus 1 is a 1. So it's 1 squared. 5 times
1 squared is five. And 10 minus 5 is 5. I
get 5 out here.
Ok? And then, I can go and do the math. If
it's 2.1, I get 4 volts here. And 2.2, I get
2.8. And so on. Ok, notice that the .1 volt
change here resulted in a - go up a .1 change
here results in a minus 1 volt change there.
So input went up by .1 volts, my output...
kerplunked down by one whole volt.
Ok, so a small change here resulted in a bigger
change there. And that's the amplification
that I am claiming here.
Ok? So. Let me show you a small demo of a
small device that I built involving such a
dependent source.
Let's do it here.
Ok. So on my s axis, here is VI. And VO is
on my y axis. And focus on this little point
here.
Ok? Right now my VI is zero. And so therefore
that's my output. I will gradually increase
VI, we're going to watch the output and see
how it behaves. Pretty much like the little
graph I drew for you.
So I'm increasing VI. Ok, notice that invitially
the current source is off, the dependent source
is off, so I move straight down. Ok, nothing
happens. Until I hit a value at which the
the current source begins to come on. And
then I begin to see a drop in the output as
the current source begins to conduct current.
So you see that as I increase the voltage
VI, boom! You see the huge drop.
Ok, notice that for a small change, I'm now
getting a big drop in the output. Ok?
So let's pause here for a second, and in the
last couple of minutes, I want to cover one
last point.
Notice that the curve I've shown you up there
looks like the curve up here: it goes kaboom!
and drops according to come kind of formulation
that I've shown you here.
In the last couple of minutes, let me discuss
a small point that's a practical issue.
In the curve that I showed you, in the mathematics
that I gave you, if you just go by the math.
So what I'm about to show you will differentiate
a mathematician from an electrical engineer.
Mathematicians would have taken the curve,
and reported it like this. This is zero.
Mathematically, that equation says that starting
here, this current simply goes down. But if
I told you this device that I have here, this
dependent source is a practical dependent
source, a device that I have physically built,
and I also say that it's a passive device.
In other words, it cannot produce power. It's
like a little resistor. It doesn't produce
power. It's a passive device.
So if it's a passive device, if I tell you
that, then you'll say, Something doesn't make
sense here. Mathematically, it says it should
look like this. But what's special about a
point down here? The point down here says
the output has gone negative. This is zero
here. The output has gone negative. And my
current source is still supplying a current.
Ok, so up here, the voltage across the device
is positive, and it's supplying a current,
so it's consuming power like a resistor. Like
all bad little resistors do, they burn power.
So here, on the other hand, my output is going
to be negative, but it's still sitting there
sinking current. Ok, because VO is negative,
but my current is still in the same direction,
what has now happened is the device has begun
to supply power.
So mathematically, this curve says the device
has begun to supply power.
It turns out it's not a practical device,
it's a passive device. So it cannot go here.
So what happens is that somewhere along here,
our model breaks down. The equation I've shown
you for the current source, where is it?
This model breaks down.
When V0 becomes very small, the model breaks
down and it no longer behaves like a current
source.
It begins to behave more and more like a resistor.
And what happens realistically, is that the
output goes down and then kind of becomes
a zero-hugging line. I'll show you that in
a second.
And it doesn't - for this particular device
it doesn't really go down here.
Let me just show you that part. So notice
for that device, mathematically, just by that
model, it should have just gone through the
floor and it points through to the corridor
below, but this is a prcatical device.
So notice that the model breaks down. And
that's what begins to happen.
Ok, the device stops behaving like a dependent
current source, rather it behaves like some
corny old resistor or something like that
and saturates out. Ok.